I know this is Dr. Kevin Connors, and we're going to go over your right tutorial how to use this machine that we're
decided to, every desire to help you in every way. So let's follow through this. This video is also going
to be on your computer itself. So if you need a review on how to use this, this is going to be placed on your
desktop of your right computer. So that will be a nice little benefit too. The pictures that we use in
this video, see these pictures here are in the back of your binder. So your new patient binder has
these pictures and it's as easy as pie. It's really easy. We tell people that if you've never used a
computer, it's going to be a little challenging. If you know how to use a computer well enough to
email somebody, it's you're going to be just fine. So it's fairly easy to learn. So this picture here
says there's some things that you need to know about the back of your right machine. There's fuses that
are extra fuses taped to the back of your right machine. There may be an extra transistor. That's the
thing with the little faux bonnet here. That is hot glued to the back of your right machine. And then there's two
transistors that the yellow arrow goes to that can heat up and burn out. That's why there's an extra one.
But quite honestly, I may be replaced in a dozen of these in a dozen years. And it's because people
used it not having it plugged into a power search control or they had electrical storm or something
like that. So that's where you'll burn out a transistor. The other way that you'll burn out a
transistor is if you run the thing without the bolt plugged in. So don't do that. There is a child's
safety switch. If you're looking at the machine to the right of the machine on the bottom, but not in any
of the newer machines. So if yours is the newest model, it does not have the child's safety switch. We're
able to get that taken off, which is very nice. So if you have a little bit older early 2017 model
and before, then they'll have a child's safety switch. Make sure that's toggled up. The front of your
machine, the front of your machine has a power button on the left, the output control right next to it,
which is always need to be all the way correct to the clockwise direction. The bulb toggle,
very, very important. It says bath or bulb. I always have it in the bulb position if you're using the
bulb. Make sense? Well, what's the bath for? Well, there is a second apparatus that you could
purchase that plugs into the bottom right hand corner of your machine. That big little
plug-in thing that you're not using. If you don't have the bath apparatus, the bath apparatus is
like an iron cleanse machine. It helps pull stuff out of your like a bucket of water that you would
put your hands or your feet in. There is an accessory toggle that says color one. You could
toggle that either way because you're not using a color one ground. Then the bulb is plugged into the
center of the machine where there's a black plug and a red plug that your bulb has on the plugs,
either a red or a black end to it. You plug the red into the red and the black into the black. Pretty easy.
Then on the far right upper there's LED indicator lights. That has to do that the machine is
running. It'll be a happy day in paradise for you when you're a little indicator lights bird out
because that's the most annoying thing about the entire life machine of those indicator lights.
In nine, for a long time, I actually put a piece of black tape over them to cover them up.
They can bring a bird out and work at the machine is still money so just so you know
that is something to look for. The rife setup you're going to plug in your computer. Your
computer needs to be plugged into the same surge protector that you're plugging in the rife
machine so you want to use a surge protector. This is a high voltage machine that rife is and you
don't want it to be damaged by an electrical failure or surges in electricity in your house for
whatever reason. Plug the computer into that also. You should always have the computer plugged in
and you should always run it plugged in. So if you're not running it off the batteries, computers
use, you know, produce like one tenth the EMFs. So you always want to plug it in and use it off of
home power. Then you plug the USB from the rife machine into the USB port. Make sure you plug it
into the USB port because we have people call and say it's not working. Is it plugged into the USB
port? No, sorry. So plug it into the USB port and then you plug the bulb in. The bulb again is red
to red, black to black and then you put the bulb in your bed with you. So I've told you that I
in our house I have the rife machine, the computer itself is sitting on the bedside stand next to my
side of the bed. Then we have the rife machine itself is underneath our bed because to be the lights
that come out of the rife front are the most annoying. And when we moved our bedroom around I took
the black tape off and cleaned it up but I put the rife machine under the bed. Therefore the wires
that come out of the front of the rife machine will never get caught on somebody's foot and pulled out
or something like that. And then so the wires come out of the rife machine, they go behind my bed
and they come up between behind my headboard and the mattress and the bulb is always light in our bed.
We make the covers over the top of the bulb. You'll get used to it. So that when you turn on the rife
yet it's going to be ready to go. You get under your covers the bulb is already shining and you're
ready to go and you're running your program. So your daily use is just that. You're going to time to
go to bed. You open up the computer because you've closed it the night before. You open up the computer,
you boot up the computer so that the rife the computer turns on and you can see the little rife
icon on the desktop. Double click on that rife icon because that's the rife program and you open up
the rife program. Then you go to your folder. If you have to hit open home you can. If you hit
open you'll go back to the folder that you were last in and then you go to your folder. Now this is
the first time you opened up the rife program. You'll want to hit open home and then you'll see
a whole bunch of folders. So remember your rife machine you're going home with has well over a
thousand maybe even two thousand programs on it. But the majority of the time you're going to be
using the programs that I created for you and I put it in a folder that has AA and your name so it
will come up first alphabetically. So it should be the top folder in the program.
Double click on the folder and then you'll see your name under your name there and it'll come up
Sunday Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday and whatever day it is today you click on that
day that will open up that day's program and then you hit run and you run the program.
It's literally that easy but don't forget the next day.
Shot the computer once you hit run on the computer it sends the program to the rife machine.
Literally you could disconnect the computer and walk away with it if you want
the rife would then continue to run that program until it times out. Now understand I wrote the
programs for you that are longer than a typical person would sleep. Typically I write eight to
nine to 10 hour programs knowing that people are only going to be in bed seven six seven eight hours
because the end of what is going to recycle back in I just want if you go to bed early and you're going
to read a book or watch some TV or something like that I want you to get as much in as possible.
So you don't have to be sleeping for this to work just run it you're going to bed you're going to be
in the vicinity of the rife machine turn it on okay. Get used to just turn it and it takes an extra
30 seconds of the day believe it or not I've gotten people's rife's back and I could tell if you
use it or not because there's a secret way for me to tell that and I've had people not do well
and then look and see that they only run their rife machine about one fourth at the time it's like okay
there's no excuses that so make sure you turn it on every night it's pretty easy if you ever want to
pause it you could hit the pause button and then come back and you have to hit pause again to
pause it but I tell you why are you going to do that don't do it just leave it running but I get
up to go to the bathroom then get up to go to the bathroom you'll get those frequencies again.
So don't stop the machine don't open it up in the middle of the night have to pause it don't do that
once you hit run at night before you go to bed it's running don't change it just let it run if you
have to get on I have to get up and walk around for an hour well get up and walk around for an hour
then come back and lay down again so do not stop it just run it now if you are running a program
in three the day or let's say you hit well it's Tuesday you actually hit Monday's program by accident oh
I just ran that last day then hit stop and go back to open to get back to the file that you read or
go to open home and then back to AA your program and go to Tuesday and have you run again so you could
use stop so I tell people the top bar the the only thing you're really going to hit is open run stop
and open home really that's what you're going to hit that's all you're going to use
now you may during the day run some other files that's great so oh I got really bad pain my knee has
been really hurting me run the pain program oh I just don't feel good I feel like I got a cold or
flu coming up run a cold and flu on coming program this is a wonderful tool the biggest mistake
I see with people with the right machine as they don't use it so use it run some of the other
programs do the same thing go to open home look at the program you want to run click on it there's a
whole bunch of different general use programs that you could use that can be extremely beneficial for
you so use the right there's no excuse this should be your go to for everybody in the house
your child has a problem use does it ever is there a right program for that run the right program
so we get the latest testimonials from people who say oh I read it by planter
when the planter awards program and my planter awards filler well that's fantastic okay it's not
going to cure everybody's planter awards but planter awards are a virus so we run the program
so make sure you use it common questions can I use other electronics can I watch TV can I listen to
the radio can I can I listen to you know by iPod while I yes you can so you can run other
electronics while running the right it may interfere with radio signals we've had people say that
I don't run the radio in in our bedroom but we've had people say it makes the you know something go
freaky with the radio that's a possibility um but yes you can use other electronics nothing
it's going to interfere with the right frequency right the right frequency might interfere with something else
but the biggest complaint we get if it's a complaint people say as they think they can get a
static electricity shocks yes you can you're running frequencies so if you're getting a lot of
shocks there could be a couple possibilities number one your house is very dry that's a
possibility if you get a lot of static electric shocks with the right machine number two you are very
dry meeting your dehydrated make sure you're hydrated um number three it can be just the
it's just the the frequencies that's running at that time so many times if it's running at a very high
frequency you're going to be more prone to static electric shocks and number four um we might need
to use a ground in your man so just let us know if it continues as it becomes really aggravated
and um I will talk to you about possibly using some grounding next question can we run night
programs during the day absolutely so on some people's programs I already wrote you some day programs
run those during the day or certainly run any other programs you want during the day on other
people I did not write you yours you know specific day programs you can run the night programs during
the day and understand your programs are not sequential so do I have to run bug day and then Tuesday
and then Wednesday what if I messed up and actually ran Tuesday when did I mess up the sequence no there's
no sequence to them so you can run a day program I'm gonna run bug day during the day but I only
read it for three hours well this is stop it hit stop so no problem with doing that next question
is it normal to feel achy or cold or flu is coming down after using the right um maybe yes
depending on what you got going on so if we're doing a lot of kill programs what if you have
Lyme disease or some other bacteria or something like that then yes we don't want to hurt you we need
to move the ball away so if you're listening to this and you're a Lyme patient you cannot
herks that's my rule number one so if you feel achy after using the right then we need to put the ball
button to the bed or move it farther away from you for by cancer patients if you feel achy after
using the right that's a good thing suck it up and keep charging through because we're not herksy
with the cancer patient so we are killing cancer cells and we need to do that if you have any other
questions about this make sure you contact us or jump on our zoom calls or whatever to get your
questions answered there's a whole troubleshooting guide um in the back of your binder um the biggest
the stakes that we see that people make is that it comes up a USB error that's very common that it'll
in the right frequencies will feedback to the computer and it'll think that it doesn't have that
USB connection sometimes you just need to unplug the USB cable and plug it back in or
the other mistake that we see people make is that they don't power down their computer itself
and reboot it enough that's fine I do I'm really bad at that so if I get that USB error if I can
if I don't unplug the USB cable plug it back in and it doesn't work right away then I got to reboot
the computer you'll get also run error messages where it thinks it's still running
even though it's not running it'll say you have to you have to stop the it's running it's still
running it'll tell you that the program's still running just hit okay and hit stop and then hit
and then run it again so it's in the whole idea is the whole problem is that we're running frequencies
so when you're running frequencies it can feedback to the computer and the computer thinks it's
stopped or thinks it's still running and you have to dis reboot that the right program may state
that there's time left on the program or the countdown on the timer won't be accurate you shouldn't
be looking at anyhow because your rule number one was to as soon as you hit run you close the computer
so that shouldn't be an issue contact us or to write with any other technical issues usually they're
pretty easy to fix if it's something with the the right machine itself true right is the person
to help you with that if you send it back to us we can't fix it we have to send it to them so
we that's a rare happening though the machine I am at home is at the time of this recording is I
think six years old and it still runs great by sudden this machine is six years old still runs great
my daughter's machine is at least that old still runs great so there's never a really an issue
so great I hope this was helpful make sure you look at the guide in your binder as well thanks